I would imagine you had offered a bunch
of scripts and you're looking at a lot
of different projects what was it about
this one that said I need to do this um
well I've read quite a few World War 2
stories or pulse World War 2 movies what
made me excited about this one the
potential of this movie was it felt very
different it felt very new once it was
in because that World War 2 narrative is
often quite good versus bad it's not
very nuanced it's often every one of
this side of the Allies are a hero and
everyone in Germany is a villain I
thought it was interesting to read
something that had a bit more complexity
and I read the novel the aftermath and I
thought it was fascinating in the fact
that this guy this German is not your
stereotypical evil Nazi but he's also
not a hero he's not Schindler is not
fighting as Nazis he is trying to
survive in Germany during the war try
and protect his daughter he's morally
compromised because he lives in a house
paid for by his wife's family's money
and they were all members of the Nazi
Party so there's a complexity there that
makes made it very interesting to me
yeah I actually liked that all the
characters were not black and white -
yeah everyone had that sort of the gray
yeah and it wasn't like her like Karis
husband Jason Clarke's character he's
not the bad guy or like the evil like so
it some chaps in you know the classic
case in those movies just like she's
with someone who's not a very nice guy
or doesn't pay attention to her or it's
just like a you know not really not a
cool guy so like it wasn't you know like
well she should leave her guy and go for
this new guy this makes it the goal was
obviously to make this difficult for the
audience and to see both sides of the
story and to understand the issues
they're dealing with and the issues that
we are dealing with and why she might be
torn I'm always curious some actors I
speak to love rehearsals and they want
to do as many rehearsals that they can
and others want to play it a little bit
looser like a little bit but they want
to keep it fresh on set
how do you like to prepare for a role
and how was it on this uh for me it's it
kind of depends on the scene there
definitely I'm quite enjoy reversals I
it again it depends on scene if it's a
technical scene I definitely think it's
helpful on I like running the lines the
scene a couple of times even if you're
just sitting down doing it I find that
quite it's an opportunity to play around
with it and try different things but
then there are moments where I find it
useful to not rehearse at all to just
jump in to me kind of depends on the
scene itself sure I am I heard that you
basically are you flew in here for from
a certain movie that I'm looking forward
to for you know for press yeah I have to
ask you I butchered the way I wanted to
bring this question up but I have to ask
you I'm so excited for Godzilla Kong
what can you tease people on we've been
shooting for two months we were in
Hawaii for a month we're in Australia
we've been in Australia for a month I
just hear I fly back tomorrow morning to
continuing I'm having so much fun I'm
loving it I really am it's totally quite
different from the aftermath and for
most weeks I've been doing the past two
years I've done a lot of more slightly
more cerebral quite intense emotionally
intense dramas so in that way it was
quite cathartic I was excited to go and
do something big and fun and it's I love
the character I play in it and visually
it's it's pretty pretty extraordinary
cannot wait
I already got to go Congrats on
everything thank you
you